today right now is the 50th anniversary  the moon landing I remember that I  remoter than a lot of you I remember  that I remember as a little kid and my  parents waking me up that night and  saying haha you missed it  for jerks man a lot of anniversaries  here at comic-con Godzilla is turning 65  this year yeah so not only is he  Godzilla king of monsters but now he  spends all day watching fox news  [Applause]  a lot of stuff happening here there's so  much that happens here at Comic Con  there's a documentary debuting at  comic-con this year about elite  cosplayers who compete around the globe  they travel all around and compete  around the globe  yeah the title that documentary is  unemployed  [Applause]